We..don't have to imagine any more.
Oh, Elden Ring..It has an open world, with
roaming encounters that can be engaged in
different environments..Our character can
use stealth, jump, and fight on horseback.This
mount can double jump, boost jump..and vanish
into thin air, as we leap off it. and as always..the
game has this unparalleled art direction and
world building.
From Software are kings.Elden Ring is coming
to current AND next generation consoles, and
PC, on January 21st, 2022.. but until then,
let's just gush about this trailer, and talk
about some of the things you might have missed.
1The tarnished will soon return.Guided by
grace, once lost.
This first part reminds me of Sekiro's opening
cinematic, where the maiden approaches us
after suffering a major setback.
She affectionately pats the creature that
is, or will be, our mount..takes off her ring,
for some reason..and instantly fulfils that
ever-present firekeeper role that is so core
to these games.Oh, and that enormous tree?
The official site calls it the "Erdtree" (note:
Erde means "earth" in German, but could also
mean "ancient or ancestral" if it comes from
High Old German), and it quite clearly has
its roots in Yggdrasil, the World Tree of
Norse mythology..and perhaps the World Spiral
Tree of Berserk..but we'll talk about that
in the lore video, so subscribe for that.
At any rate, the website says that at the
source of the Erdtree, "was the Elden Ring,
which has been shattered".
And now, the Tarnished will soon return..guided
by grace, once lost.
We play as these characters..and just as we
were undead, unkindled ash, good hunters in
games before this, now, we are Tarnished.
The word "tarnish" has two meanings.
First, it's when something, usually a metal,
loses its lustre, or becomes corroded.
Take the Valkyrie, for example.
Her arm is literally corroding, losing its
lustre.
Even our hair appears to have lost that red
lustre that she, and the giant in the previous
trailer, retain.
Second, when something is tarnished it can
mean it's less valuable, or less respected.
According to the official site, "the Tarnished
were spurned by the grace of gold and exiled"..thus,
they have become "less valuable and respected".
So tarnished is a beautiful word to use here,
because both definitions of the word seem
to applySecond, it's when something becomes
less valuable, or respected.
It's a beautiful word to use here, because
both meanings seem to apply.
Secondly, according to the official site,
"the Tarnished were spurned by the grace of
gold and exiled"..thus, they have also become
"less valuable and respected".
This brings us to the "Golden Order".
It seems we, as Tarnished..were once a part
of it, and exiled long ago.
For the Elden Ring has been shattered, and..2The
Golden Order is broken to its core.Let's talk
about our mount, who a lot of people have
started calling Yakul, on account of its similarities
to the Red Elk in Princess Mononoke.
This wouldn't be the first time Miyazaki or
his designers were inspired by that movie..and
Yakul here is certainly capable of some seriously
gravity-defying jumps, just like his movie
counterpart.These scenes are so beautiful..it's
going to be so fun riding through open plains..over
rocky terrain..past giant walking castle islands
with giant dongs..On the Japanese Elden Ring
site, it's called a "spirit horse"..which
explains its ability to suddenly appear and
vanish beneath us.
This has interesting implications for the
gameplay - Imagine summoning Yakul in combat
for a quick burst of speed, or in order to
make a getaway.It also makes me wonder when
it is beneficial to engage in mounted combat,
vs traditional combat.
Perhaps mounted combat is really good against
other mounted enemies, for example?
- that's what happens in this scene after
all - the player character engages in a sort
of joust with a mounted enemy..charging their
sword attack, and releasing at just the right
moment.
Of course, it doesn't look like mounted combat
is always going to be this chivalrous.
The character in this screenshot, for example..looks
just about ready to leap off his horse, onto
us..and later on in the trailer, we do exactly
that..with Yakul vanishing beneath us.
This mob of hollows and the mounted enemy
are escorts, walking with the two giants and
the carriage they pull via a spike and chain
plunged through their chests.
What's cool about this encounter.. is that
because this is an open world, wandering mobs
like this will absolutely venture through
different territories and terrains..meaning
every player might encounter them in different
places..with different advantages and disadvantages.In
fact, that's exactly what's happening in this
screenshot.
According to a press release, Elden Ring will
have a "natural weather and time-or-day progression",
and here, we see the player sneaking in some
tall grass, their stealth enhanced by the
cover of rainfall, and night.
If the stealth system from Sekiro is truly
in place, then I bet you can take out the
caravan one by one, rather than head-on in
the daytime, as we saw in the video.
I bet the loot is pretty good - these hollows
are literally carrying chests, after all..Thinking
critically about how to use the open world
to your advantage sounds like so much fun.
I bet you can do the same thing here with
the walking island.
We all noticed the giant dong beneath..but
did you see that there's also a building above?
I bet you can wait for this island to wander
into different territory, and jump off a nearby
cliff ON to the island.
Open world games are at their best with dynamic
events and puzzles like this..and it looks
like FROM are thinking really creatively.
I'm here for it.
3.Foul Tarnished,In search of the Elden RingEmboldened
by the flame of ambition.Someone must extinguish
thy flame.
The
voice acting here is incredible, timed perfectly
with the swell of the music and the scenery
in the trailer..but it's that "flame of ambition"
line I love the most - because it speaks to
the slight tonal shift this game has from
Dark Souls.
Dark Souls is the story of downtrodden undead
trying to hold onto their vestiges of life..but
the Tarnished feel like they're fighting for
their right to the glory, lordship, and status
that they've been denied.
That's a significant difference, in my opinion.This
increased sense of character agency translates
well to the open world.
Here, you have more control over you path
- choosing which castles to conquer, or which
caves to explore.
I'm also really excited for the gameplay variety
this should introduce..because you'll be going
between an open world with dynamic encounters,
to more tightly designed dungeons with the
level design that we know and love.
In many of these spaces, the character wields
a torch - giving you light in exchange for
a shield, or two-handing your weapon.
Speaking of weapons, many seem to come with
animations pulled straight from Dark Souls
3 - for example, this is the weapon art of
the Old Wolf Curved Sword..this is literally
the quickstep animation you get from holding
a dagger or short axe..this is the rolling
attack of the short bow, and there are many
similar magic weaopn arts, as well.4They will
fight, and they will die.In an undending curse.That..sounds
familiar.
Honestly, there's a lot familiar in this trailer
- but there's so much that's new, as well.
The terrain is so traversable..and you can
even leap off of Yakul to get the jump on
enemies, as his spirit dissipates beneath
you.So, mentioned right after your "spirit
horse", the website also mentions "spirit
bodies", summonable help that seem a little
bit more unique than the usual phantoms we
summon in Souls games.
There's even a spirit bird in one of these
screenshots that reminds me of Father Owl's
summon..but I can't be sure this is the same
thing.
It's probably a good time to mention again
that the game has multiplayer, probably very
similar to what we had in Dark Souls, so don't
worry about that.
But here is the last scene I want to talk
about in this segment.
It's night here, more evidence of a rolling
day and night system in the game..but most
interestingly, the character is sitting at
a small camp.
Cut content in Dark Souls 3 showed them experimenting
with the idea of moveable bonfires and checkpoints..so
what if they finally implemented this idea
in Elden Ring?
What if you can move your camp around, starting
back here if you die?
It would make a lot of sense for an open world
game like this..and I'm willing to bet that's
exactly what's going on here.
For how else is a ch ampion, or a Lord, to
be born?
According to Namco's official site, it's our
goal to "become the Elden Lord"..and it's
probably no coincidence that this line about
lords aligns with our fight against the Valkyrie
character, who is clearly more lordly than
we are.
Unlike us, her long hair is bright red..so
I wonder if ours is simply faded, and what
our relation to her might be.
Later, when I feel more confident, I'll talk
more deeply about the lore we know so far..so
please, subscribe for that.
Now, you might have been too distracted by
the archdragon plucking lightning bolts from
the sky to notice, but Yakul actually performs
a double jump here.
The player also gets a jump of their own,
just like in Sekiro..so expect a LOT of verticality
to be present in these levels..and expect
lots of hidden paths to explore.
Take these graves on this cliff face, for
instance...
Well..a lowly Tarnished, playing as a Lord.
I command thee KNEEL!
This..appears to be the same character from
the original trailer, who was stitching arms
together.
He's been busy these past two years, apparently..and
now has a cascade of limbs, some clutching
additional weapons, to barrage you with.
He even stitches a dragon head onto one arm
at some point..holy shit.
He seems to be important..and his main weapon
has a lion crest on it..the same crest you
see on many enemies and banners throughout
this trailer.
Perhaps he's the main boss of this area?
Speaking of which..I assume this area..with
the tree, and the plains, and the castle..I
assume it's all a part of one kingdom, and
that there are many other open worlds to explore
that we haven't seen yet.
But thank you for watching and supporting,
and enjoy watching the channel for the next
few weeks, as we discuss this game to death.
I'll see you soon.
So two years ago, when the Elden Ring trailer
first aired..I had a brilliant idea.
I know!
I'll commission a merch design inspired by
Elden Ring, and I'll release it the next time
they release elden ring news.
Well..now, 700 days later..it's finally here.
The elden valkyrie..a helmet design inspired
by the valkyrie character in the e3 trialer.